gráfica el conjunto de solución del
siguiente sistema y nos dan un sistema
de desigualdades
jay mayor que x 8 y jay menor que 5 - x
graphic hemos el conjunto de solución
para cada una de estas desigualdades y
veremos que básicamente donde se
traslapan las soluciones de dichos
conjuntos es la solución del sistema de
desigualdades déjame graficar los ejes
coordenadas aquí aquí tenemos nuestro
eje x
y aquí tenemos
nuestro eje y nuestro eje y ahora voy a
graficar la recta frontera de esta
desigualdad mayor a x 8 la recta
frontera es igual a x menos 8 pero no va
a incluir porque aquí es mayor que x
menos 8 practiquemos entonces la recta
igual a x menos 8 esta recta tiene una
ordenada al origen de menos 8 cuando x
es igual a 0 y es igual a menos 8 aquí
tenemos menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 56 menos
78 aquí está la ordenada al origen que
es 0 como a menos 8 y luego vemos que la
pendiente es 1 aquí no se ve lo puedo
escribir que es la pendiente de la recta
que es igual a 1 simplemente podría
trazar la por aquí o puede ubicar el
punto 80 sigue es igual a 0 x es igual a
8 12345678 aquí lo tenemos la recta
tiene pendiente uno cuando x avanza 1 a
la derecha y avanza 1 hacia arriba
trazamos la recta de hecho no
un trazo sólido al usar un trazo sólido
estaría dibujando esta recta que
recordemos que no va a estar en la
solución por la desigualdad es mayor que
x menos 8 lo va a poner entonces como
una línea punteada que va a mostrar la
frontera sin incluir la recta en el
conjunto solución déjame hacer esto en
otro color este va a ser el color de esa
línea más bien de esa desigualdad para
ser más precisos así que esta es la
frontera de la desigualdad entonces para
la desigualdad ye mayor que x menos 8 si
tomas un valor de jay igual a x menos 8
nos va a llevar a esa línea frontera
nosotros queremos los valores de ye que
son mayores a x menos 8 es decir que se
encuentran por arriba de esta recta va a
ser entonces esta región aquí por arriba
de la recta y si eso te confunde porque
bueno siempre puedes pensar que si es
mayor que es por arriba y si es menor
que es por abajo de la frontera pero si
eso te confunde siempre puedes agarrar
puntos de prueba por ejemplo el punto
cero cero vamos a probar la desigualdad
cero es mayor que cero menos ocho está
bien cero es mayor que menos ocho es un
punto que está dentro de la ley
con solución de la desigualdad y si
elevamos un punto fuera de la región
solución como el punto 10 0 lo probamos
aquí 10 menos 8 es 20 no es mayor que 10
menos 8 por eso ese punto 10,0 está
fuera de la región solución pero en
general lo que puedes pensar es que si
esta es la línea frontera una
desigualdad mayor que va a estar por
arriba de esta línea frontera resolvamos
esta desigualdad ahora la línea frontera
es igual a 5 - x la línea frontera es
igual a 5 - x hagamos su gráfica cuando
x es igual a 0 y es igual a 5 1 2 3 4 5
y esta recta tiene pendiente menos 1
podemos escribir así como ye igual a
menos 1 x + 5 es decir ésta va a pasar
por 50 otra manera de verlo es cuando
hoy es igual a 0 x tiene que ser igual a
5 es decir entonces va a pasar por el
punto 1 2 3 4 5 0 nos movemos uno a la
derecha bajamos 1 tenemos una pendiente
de menos 1 se va a ver entonces así
voy a usar también una línea punteada
una línea punteada para marcar esta
frontera y estoy usando una línea
punteada porque es menor a 5
x si hubiera sido igual a 5 x usaría una
línea sólida o también si hubiera sido y
menor o igual que 5 menos x también
usaría una línea sólida aquí así que
para cada valor de y esta línea de aquí
la frontera va a ser los valores que son
5 - x abajo de esta línea frontera son
los valores de ye que son menores a 5 -
x esta zona de aquí son puntos cuya i es
menor a 5 menos x y de nueva cuenta
puedes probar para distintos valores por
ejemplo el punto 00 cumple con la
desigualdad 0 es menor que 5 - 0 0 es
menor que 5 cumple con la desigualdad
puedes probar algo fuera de la región
como 0 10 ver que no cumplen 0 0 no es
menor que 5 menos 10 que es menos 5
entonces como dijimos todo lo que está
debajo de la línea la solución de la
desigualdad y como mencionamos el
conjunto solución para este sistema son
las coordenadas
y que satisfacen ambas desigualdades así
que todos los sombreados en púrpura
satisface la segunda desigualdad y todos
los sombreados en verde satisface la
primera desigualdad así que los puntos
que satisfacen ambas es el traslape de
estas regiones es toda esta región en
azul es pero esto no sea muy confuso
esta región en azul que tenemos aquí es
la región que tenemos aquí por debajo de
la línea púrpura y a la izquierda y por
arriba de la línea verde esta zona de
azul es la zona solución del sistema
desigualdades y no incluimos las rectas
de frontera